えーでは  ちょっとよろしいですか
はい  今ペッチャーですけども
あのペッチャーっていうのはパーラっていう言葉でも同じ意味で
同じものですね  あの世と言いますと
日本人はあの なんかどっか遠い世界にあるような世界と思ってたんですけども
そういう捉え方が良くないですよね
それどれぐらい遠いか知らないと答えられません
あの最高浄土とか あの遠いどこかわからない
遠いところにあるというあの世って
うん まあそれは今の自分の理解範囲で理解すればいいでしょう
まあどんどん理解増えていくとね
また定義が変わるしね
だから今も悩んで それからも悩むという風にした方がいつでも伸びます
それは ゴムみたいに それからということは
次の刹那と考えてもいいという
ん？ 次の刹那と考えていいわけですか
それでも無限に行くでしょ
いくらしたっても だから今も悩んで
これからも悩むということになっちゃうと
いつでもこれからですからね
今も悩む だからこれから悩むことになるという
かなり伸びるんですね
その悪循環 切らない限りは
すいません もう一つ  はい
この偈は  在家の人のことを言ってるというふうに理解してよろしいでしょうか
その出家の人たちは その悪とか善とかに囚われずに生きていくのがいいのかなと思ってるんですけども
うん 仏説は別に出家と在家ということはあまり気にしない
生命に対して言ってるんです
この真理は犬猫にも当てはまります
あいつら聞かないだけで
全ての生命に 神々にも当てはまります
真理っていうのはそういうものなんです
たまにそのそのケースバイケースで人間だけに限って言う時もあるし
あの比丘たち出家だけに限って言う場合もあるし
その時ははっきりしています
今の偈は一般論で あの普遍的な真理なんです
出家に限る 在家に限るではなくて
出家にも在家にも同じことなんです
であの 私は犬のことを見ているところで
やっぱり失敗する犬たちもいますね
これは面白いんですよ
まあ人間はみんな失敗ですけど
まあ犬たちの中でも ちょっと何かでショック受けちゃうと
あ 悪いことしちゃったとかね
それからずっとそればっかり悩んで
もう性格も悪くなっちゃって
臆病になっちゃって どうにもならなくなる
だから法則同じなんですよ
どうにもならない で それでもう誰か別な人でも
もう時々別な人が親切に飼っても
あの傷跡が消えないっていうことはあるんですよ
だからこの過去の失敗に悩むということはね
結構大変ですよ だからこの動物を観察したってのも
それそれみんな別々性格持ってるっていうことは見えるでしょうし
で 臆病者もいて 凶暴なやつもいてとかね
落ち込み型の型もいるし
とにかく今日のところは
在家のという話ではなくて
普遍的な全ての生命に
どんな生命でも法則は同じということなんです
心という存在があった時に現れる法則そのものっていう
そうですね 生命というのは心と体ですからね
それで幸福っていうのは体のことじゃないんです
心のこと  他に何か質問ありませんか？ このソーソーパッソーソーチャッティーソーヴィハンニャーというというのは
これは結局もうその悩みがあるっていうことは
すなわちもうそこで自壊しとる
自滅しとるっていう風に考えていいわけですか
悩みがあるから その将来的に自滅するっていうのも
悩みがあるっていうことは
もうそこで自分が幸せじゃないっていうことの自滅してますっていう
インスタント的にそういう風に考える
ですぐへりくつにめっちゃってですね
[笑い]もう寿命尽きてるんだったらもう終わりでしょ
だったら もうお手上げで
そんなことではない もうそうそう
ソーチャティ そうヴィハンニャティっていうのは
まあちょっとパーリ語だったらその方がすぐ出てきますけど
まあソーチャティ ソーチャティ
ソーチャティ ソーチャティ
そういうことによって
その連続性でこいつはヴィハンニャティと呼んでやって
えーと もうすでに破滅っていう意味ではないんですね
そんな調子で言ってみろ
破滅やという意味なんです
だから この悩む悩む悩む悩む悩むことの積み重ねを総合的に計算すると
もう破滅とレッテルの羽がある
ということで 悩んだイコールもう破滅っていうことを言っちゃうと
理屈もう全然崩れてます
ということはもうお手上げ
だったら大きな教えはそんなこと言ったって意味がないんですよ
人が死んでから やっぱりこの薬飲ませたらよかったんではないかとかね
やっぱりあの病院に連れて行った方が良かったんですよとか
うるさいでしょ そんなこと言ってももう終わりだからね
死んだんだからね だからヴィハンニャティ
悩んだ時点で破滅っていうことは成り立たない
もっとクリアな論理的に考えてください
その まあその死ぬとか壊れるっていうのをその刹那単位で考えると
結局刹那単位でずっと永久に続いていくステップがあるとすれば
そこのステップで失敗しました
その次のステップも失敗しました
ずっとそれが癖的に続いているわけですから
そこで悩んだという ソーチャティという状態があるっていうことは
もうそこでそのタイムスライスはもうヴィハンニャティっていうことじゃないですか
次のタイムスライスはどうします？ タイム
次のタイムスライスはよくわからないです
それは因果関係ちょっとわからないんですけど
とにかくその思考は正しくないんですよ
このヴィハンニャティということは
この まとめていうことがないんです
だからソーチャティということは瞬間のことで
一個のタイムスライスで言うんです
もうもう悩んでいると
その人はそれを持ち運んで
次の瞬間でも悩む それ持ち運んで次の瞬間でも悩むことになる
だから今悩むと次にも悩むんだよと
そうするとどうなることかというと
ヴィハンニャティになるんだよということであって
ヴィハンニャティっていうのは
破滅っていう言葉使っちゃうと
もう終わったっていうことでしょ
でも物事には終わりがないんだから
ずーっと流れるんだからね
だからこれ詩ですから
それは文学的にそういう風に使うんです
言葉は これはまああの科学的な
ちょっとした論文的な
もうもう何とかではないんです
詩ですよ 詩ですから まあそこら辺でちょっと文学的に見るんです
だから厳密な真理を文学的に語る世界なんです
はい まあね 他のなんか分かりやすい例がないんですかね
まあ例えば子供はね ローラースケートつけて全然もう初めてあれ
膝にあるガードなんとも使ってないとかね
それでまあ 怖がってみようではなくてますか
この滑ってみようとかね
滑ってみると立ったところでまた転がる
また立ってまた転がる
それでまた痛い痛いとね
それちょっと滑ったらまた転がったりして
それまた痛いとかね それでその瞬間瞬間に痛いでしょ
それまとめて母親がお前そんなことやっちゃったらもう大怪我してもう病院に運ぶことになるよって言うんですよ
だからもう買ってあげますからやめなさいと
ガード全部買ってあげますからと
ということを言わなくちゃいけないでしょ
だから転がった瞬間でそいつは終わって大怪我っていうことじゃないんです
だからって必ず大怪我して病院に運べる
運べるということでもないんです
だからまあそれはまあそれなりの次の次の瞬間に何するかっていうことで
その子が転がるたびになんとか何とか訓練を受けているならば
自分の反省しているならばね
なんで転がったんでしょうかとか
それで反省しながら行くんだってのは
ものすごく上手に見事にもう滑れるようになるでしょ
その その 要するに ソーチャティの状態をずっと続けるならばアウトですよっていう
途中で変えれば まあそれは成立しませんという
だからそう続けるんだったら
それにも違反になるということをそう言ってるんです
アウトだと しかし アウトと終わったということは成り立ちません
無常の輪廻の中では だから非観論を語っているわけじゃないんです
仏教は 仏教はいつでも悪事ばっかり取り出して言うんだけど
それはいつでも道があるんだよと
という感じで読むんです
だから非観論は間違っていて
非観論の反対はなんですか？楽観ですか？それももうもうもう間違い
これはもう偏見で だからこのどちらにしろってももうダメなんですよ
楽観で物事を見ちゃうととんでもないひどい目にあっちゃう
悲観で物事を見ちゃうと
もうそれでその人 それで終わっちゃうんですね
人生は 事実は楽観でも悲観でもない
もうぐちゃぐちゃむちゃくちゃだからね
だからそこら辺は自分がどう運転するかというね
それで運転の仕方がありますよと
っていうところを教えているんですね
えーと あの あの目標をですね
善行為をするということと
心を育てるということと
今は話題になっているといえば
お金を儲けるっていうことを 2つの目標を持って
その人は人生を歩もうと
そしてお金を善行為をしたり
親切にしたり 慈悲の心を持てば
商売も繁盛して その 2つの目標は共に叶うことができるんだというふうな考え方というのは
どこか誤りがありますか？お金儲けるっていうのはやはりちょっと欲の行為で
悪行為のように私は思っているわけですけど
思っているわけなんですけど
とりあえずは普通の商売をしている人は
やはり皆さんに親切にしたり
お客さんに親切にしたり
いろんな人と心配したりすると
お客さんもいっぱい来て
商売もうまくいくと その 2つを追求することが
自分の親切 自分の人格も育てられるし
商売もうまくいくんだっていうことを言う人がいるんですけど
それは俗世間から見ると
まあ必ずまあそういうことなんです
そういう結論になります
しかし すごく曖昧でやりにくいんです
で 例えばお客さんにすごい真剣に親切にしたところで
そんなにまで親切になってくると
まああまり儲からないぞって
儲かるためにちょっと親切でいろいろ問題が起きたりするんですよ
でも仏教の見方は全く違う見方があるんです
そんなに儲かることを仕事すること大げさにしないんです
自慢にもしない 仏教では人は仕事をするっていうのは
これは別にどうったことないでしょうに
自慢することですか？そんなのは
というあまりにも当たり前で常識なところにしておくんですよ
自分が店やってるんだったら
お客さんにありがとうございます
ありがとうございますというふうに
そんなの当たり前ではないのと
だからそれでやっぱりこれぐらい礼をしなくちゃ
これぐらい笑わなくちゃとかね
あれが変な世界で 欲で考えてるんだからそうなっちゃうんだ
だからほとんど失敗する
失敗して儲からなく 儲かってもものすごくストレス溜まる
仏教の世界ではもう日々生きていかなくちゃいけない
瞬間瞬間も呼吸しなくちゃいけない
呼吸するたびにもう体のものはなくなったりしまったりして
それで自分一人じゃないんだから
親がいるわ 子供もいるわ
奥さんもいるわ いろいろいるし
それは人々に食べさせなくちゃいけないしということで仕事をする
まあ呼吸するぐらいのことで当たり前で取っているんです
だから仏教的にいうと仕事では疲れることはないし
仕事の特別な訓練技もいらなくなっちゃうんです
特別な訓練技っていうのは
例えば運転手だったらそれは特別な訓練で
しかし プロの運転手がお客さんにはこうやって頭下げなくちゃいけない
それは教えてあげません
そんなのは当たり前やと
で それで仕事はすごく楽々に気楽に行くんです
あの例えがわからないんですけど
シンガポールではもう結構仏教の人々の数がすごい大きいし
で 時々タクシーなんか
まあいつでもタクシーで乗ったら行くんだから
タクシー乗っちゃうと
まあ人によって別に日本のタクシー運転手全部決まりってことはないんですね
ある人が場所言ったら
そこ場所私はわかりません
ちゃんと教えてよと はい
分かりましたと で そこら辺になったら言いますよ
まだ他の運転手説教させちゃうんですよ
こちらお金払っていくのに
これはどうしてもこういう場合どうですかとかね
いろいろとかね どちらのタクシーもやっぱり楽しいんですよ
それでたまに長い距離を行っているのに
これならいいですよと
お金は という場合もあるし
だからまあそこら辺はもうやっぱり新しい国なんですけど
仏教の影響っていうのはすごい強烈に入ってるんだから
楽しいんですね だからこの
もう単純に楽でいいやと気楽で
だから仕事はその自慢するもんじゃない
なんの仕事しないであんた人間かと聞いた方がいいんですよ
あんたそれで 食べてるつもり
食べるつもりですか？と
日本 禅でもあるでしょ
何でしたっけ？働かざる者は食うべからずとかね
あれはそれだけ見るとなんかすごいキツい言葉なんですけど
仏教的に見ると まあそんなのは言う必要もないんだと
どうせ食べるんだから
そういうことで すごく気楽に
商売であろうが他の産業であろうが
もう気楽に遊びながらやると
商売だったらお客さん関係でしょうし
だから商売はそちらに成り立ってるんだから
まあこんにちは 元気ですか？今日はなんかすごい顔色なんか幸せそうだなとかなんとかやって遊びゃいいんです
わざとぐるぐるお客さんに今日はなんかすごく幸せそうな顔ですねと言ったら
そいつの誰か死んでる場合どうなる
だからあんまりこういうやりしきたりっていうのは良くない
危険 で すごくリラックスして
楽しく まあ当たり前のことで生きてみる
でないと人間にはいいことをする暇がなくなっちゃうんですよ
仕事に忙しくて これはもう無意味な忙しさなんですよ
気楽でいいのに だからこの家族のことやらね
家族の面倒見ることやら
仕事をすることやら 家の掃除洗濯
そんなのはもう当たり前で気楽でやればいいんです
気楽でやれば楽しいし
見事にうまくもいくし
だから仕事をする技 工夫というのは
仏教はもう使わない 工夫を教えると
あんたもうとっくに失格だと
人間に間違って来たんではないかと
人間に生まれたならば
そんなのも決まってるんだからね
まあ鳥で生まれて飛べないと言っちゃったら
もう まあペンギンは別として
まあ例えば本当に飛んでいる他の鳥なんか飛べないんだったらそれで終わりでしょ
人生は それ鳥が私はよく飛べますよと自慢しますかね
もし自慢しちゃうと もうあまりにバカバカしいでしょうに
ですから この人間だけ仕事を自慢するのはなんかおかしいんですよ
逆に自慢できんでしょ
仕事あるんだからとか
なんかえらい顔をしてえらい疲れた顔をしてとかね
これは仏教の世界では成り立ちませんね
まあ旅路  その 2つ目標を置く
その一つは商売がうまくいくようにっていうのは
これは当たり前のことで
っていうことで目標にするような問題じゃないんだと
心を育てるのが  それはもうそれが仕事
としての目標なんだと
そういうことですか  うん
だから仏教の場合 欲っていうのはあまり関係ないんですよ
子供が少しでもいい大学へ行きたいとか
会社に入って少しでもいいポストにいたいとか
こう思うことに対してはどういうアドバイスが適切でしょうか
それも簡単 自分の力が一杯使いなさいよと
大学はあれやらこれやらじゃなくて
あなた子供にはあなたの力いっぱいやれと
それで終わりやと 気がないもんだとなると
もうちょっと勉強できたのにとかね
それだけはもう言わないようにしなさいと
それで大体解決するでしょ
もしその子が本当に能力あったならば
自然にいい大学に入っちゃうし
あるいは強引に塾に行かせて
もう勉強させちゃって
いい大学に行ってもそこで合わな
うまくいかなくなっちゃうし
それで自分の能力もないのに
いろんな工夫してすごい難しい会社なんかに入ってしまっちゃうと最悪な状態になる可能性もあるしね
だから幸福っていうのは一生で見ないとね
一生で見るってことは日々でも見るんですよ
今日苦しんで明日の楽しみっていうのは成り立たないんです
今日は楽しがないと もし明日死んじゃうと損ばっかりだからね
だから今日は楽しいという生き方をする
だから子供は子供にあなたが出来ること勉強すること楽しいでしょうと
という結果 それだけのことで
だからやっぱりやるなりにはもう力いっぱいやるっていうね
でないと悔しいんですよ
それが欲で怒りで競争心でやっちゃうと
もう地獄なんですね 我々言うのは怒り消せ
競争心を捨てろと だからいい加減中途半端ではというわけではない
いい加減やっちゃうと
またあんたが悩むんだよと
だから 1 日でも悩むなかれと 1時間でも悩むなかれ
だから教室に行ったらふざけちゃうと
その人はすごく悩むんです
教室にいるとふざけるんじゃなくて
じーっと講義を聞く 終わった途端すごく楽しいんですよ
解放感で 終わったぞと
しかし 損してないでしょ
だからそこら辺教えてあげるべきなんですね
だからもっと勉強しようっていうよりはね
あなたその力全部出してますか？とかね
もう力出せと そのまま楽しいよと
無理をするなよと だからよく言ってほしいことは無理をするなということはやっぱり言ってもいいんですね
子供たちはやっぱりあの親の気持ちを親よりも子供たちで読んでるんだから
無理をするんですよ 悩むことがあっても言わないとかね
カッコつける これはすごい悲しいんですね
どうせ小さな生命だからね
育てなくちゃいけないしね
だからまあ 特に子供のバカなところやらね
みっともないところとかね
そこら辺も平気で受け止めるとかね
例えばすぐ何でも飽きっぽいだったらね
それは平気で じゃああんたもういつもそれ飽きっぽいだからとかとかとかね
で 何か始めたら これはまあまあ
それ何でいいですかね
あんたはよく飽きっぽいだからとか
そういう風に言っちゃうと
まあ自分 なんと子供は明るくなっちゃって
そうは言わせませんぞという気持ちになるし
だからこの親っていうのはよく誤魔化しちゃうんですね
まあ自分我に見えない
とにかく子供は世界一に見えちゃうんだから
そう見てはいけないんですね
あの全部親だから こいつの悪いところは全部知ってるんだよっていうね
っていうとこは見せないと
で それでまあ子供たちっていうのは世界ではカッコつけて頑張りますけど
もう家に戻って まあやっぱり自分の弱みやらだらしないところやら
そのままもう解放しちゃうしね
とにかく無理をするなよということと
あのやることは自分の力いっぱいやれと
負けても悔しくないんだけど
はい  あの 先ほどの悩みということなんですけども
あの良い行いと悪い行いが
またそれとは別にして
我々あの まあ家庭を持ったり
仕事を持ったりすると
子供のこと そして職場のこと
仕事の会議 あらゆる問題
人との関係とか そういう意味でいろいろあの
自分でどうにもならない問題とかですね
抱えてて それがいわゆる思い煩いでもありますし
悩みでもある それは子供の時から今までずっとそうだし
おそらく棺桶入るまでそういうのは思い煩いからおそらく自由にならないと思うんですね
で それはヴィパッサナーをし
業しても そのような あの
常に我々つきまとって
解決求められる問題が必ずあるわけですね
それが先ほどちょっとお話あったように
永遠に続いて終わりがない
我々生きてる限り 常にそれに対処しなきゃいけないわけですね
自分の行いが良い悪いとは別にして
またそのそのような生きてる上で必然っていうのが必ず出てきます
そうすると そのようなその苦しみといいますか
悩みといいますか 今やはりどうしても対処を迫られますから
それに関わり合いたくなくても関わり合っちゃうわけですよね
それは結果がいいか悪いか
また我々の次元とは別の話にもなる面があるわけですけれども
悪いが悪いで受け止めなきゃいけないし
いいはいいでよしということですが
永遠に消えないといいますか
死ぬまで逃れられないわけですよね
そうすると そのようなことがありながらも
そういう荷物 お荷物背負いながらも我々生きなきゃいけないっていうのが現実の姿だと思うんですよね
そうすると 今そのちょうどおっしゃったような形での
その悟っていない我々が生きなきゃいけない
この現実 社会ですよね
その中で我々はやはりこの
そう 仏の教えというものを一つの光といいますか
あの 一筋の光を見出しながら修行に励んでいるわけなんですが
と言いながら あの悟れてるわけではないわけですから
毎日悩んで実は生きるわけですね
這いつくばるようにして生きるようなこともあるわけですけれども
そうすると その中で悩みがなくなるというのが一つの我々にとっては夢でありますけれども
現実の問題としてやっぱないんですよね
ある瞬間はあるかもしれないけど
またこうどっと押し寄せてきますので
すっかりそれから解放されたというのは
おそらく死ぬまでないのかなという気がするんです
といって 到底比較になることないですが
これも死ぬまでという仏の修行と言いますか
続けるしかできないと思うんですけども
やはりそこは悩みがあってしょうがないというのも一つの生き方といいますか
ということで 解決じゃないですけれども
いくつかのポイントを見えます
一つは あらゆる悩みには直面したくないという
逃げたいというね 気持ちがあるんですよ
もう一つは 何か別な何か方法ないかというね
特に仏教に対してそういうアプローチしているような感じがするんですね
なんかもっと荒っぽく言えば
何か奇跡的に何か全部処理チャラにしてくれるというふうなね
悟ったら全部チャラになるぞとかね
そこら辺でこの思考のいくつかの見方ですね
思考といったっていうのはね
まあ問題は見えます で
この逃げる気持ちあると悩みがものすごく倍増します
あんたどこへ逃げるんですかと
こんな例えで見てください
海のど真ん中で自分がもう落ちているんだと
だから前見たらもう限りなく海だから
ああ怖いとこちらに逃げるぞと
どこへ逃げるんですかね
浮いてればいいでしょ
浮いてればいいんです
だから人生っていうのは面白いことに
秒単位で出てくるものは何でも問題なんですよ
だからそこから逃げようと思うと
最初から思考が失敗なんです
だから我々いうのは浮いていればいいんです
そこら辺で そこで海にそうやって落ちてる人にとっては
解決法っていうのはそこから脱出することなんです
脱出するまで船でも来るまで浮いてもらわないと
浮いている途中でこの船が来て
人を見つけて そこでもう脱出する
だからもう前の海が怖い
だから後ろの方に泳ぐぞとかね
右見たところで限りなく
だから左に泳ぐととか言っちゃうと必ずもう失敗するんですよ
そういうことで この家族があり
仕事がありとかね それで秒単位で問題が起こる
それ一つからも逃げようとしない
それから一つの問題解決したんだからといって放っともしない
まあ次 次の問題何なのかと構えればいいんですよ
だから例えば明日起きて会社に行く
今日はバリバリ元気で仕事をするんだぞと思って行ったってもわかりませんから
構えていけばいいんですよ
今日は何があってもやってやるぞと
家に行ったらもう幸せな温かい家があるんだぞと思ったってもわかりませんよ
奥さんがどんな態度 調子でいるか
子供たちはもう何かやったかとかね
わかりませんだから構えてればいいんですよ
だから当たり前やと全部
例えば子供が万引きしたんだと言って
お母さんがもうとんでもないカンカンで
もうもう怒って 父親が帰るまで待っていて
で 別に自分はまあ万引きしちゃったという感じで
そんなのはね まあその年では当たり前やと
で 当たり前で見て で 解決方法がそこに出てくるんですよ
そこで子供と話やって
まあまあやったんですかねとかね
面白かったとかね 面白かった
で もっとやれと で まあ何でもいいんで
答えはその場 だから普通で見るともう普通に問題は消えるんですよ
問題はそれじゃない それ子供が万引きしてそれは直しちゃったんだけど
その後それから永久的に問題作ってくれないかというと
それがちょっと違う それは別なことをやっちゃいますからね
これが人生なんですよ
それで仏教と修行っていうのは
仏の教えっていうのは別世界の話じゃないんですよ
そのそれにあなたはどうアプローチするかと
だからブッダの教え 釈迦さんの教えは
この時間いの人生とは全く離れてないんです
その時間の人生がブッダの教えなんです
秒単位で出てくるんだから
次の秒でどうアプローチするかと
その理性を持ちなさいと
だから 例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想したっても
日常生活でそれを応用してみないと意味がないんですよ
応用してみると 毎日問題解決するたびに知恵が出てくる
でも 残念なことに同じ問題は二度と来ないんです
でも ものは流れるんだからね
だからこの毎日毎日問題を解決していくといくということ
それがなんとなく充実感ね
幸福に繋げるんですよ
問題がないと本当にすっごいどすまらないと思いますよ
だから我々の見方なんて問題あって困った困ったっていうのは
なんで困るんです？これが面白いと
問題がないと本当に困るんですよ
何にチャレンジするかっていうことなくなっちゃうんだから
特に私ははっきり言います
もし自分の子供がすごくいい子だったら
とことん気をつけてください
ものすごい危険なんです
もうちゃんと学校に行って
親言うことをきちんと聞いて
はい わかりました はい
わかりましたと えらい問題児なんですよ
そういうすごい危険 この上辺だけ
だからもう言うことを聞かないわ
だったらものすごく育ちやすい
もうバレてるんだから性格は
だからこの毎日毎日人生はチャレンジですよ
一秒一秒チャレンジなんです
で まあ一年間もちゃんとチャレンジ受け取って頑張ったんだから
これで安全かというと
そうじゃないんです 同じ問題は二度と起きてこないんです
だからそこら辺は理解して
子供にしても一秒単位で年取っていくんだから
同じ問題を二度と作らない
自分もそうでしょうし
奥さんもそうでしょうし
会社の人々もそうでしょうしね
それでその瞬間 その瞬間で出てくる問題に
その場でその場で対応していく
それに知恵と言うんですよ
知恵というのは前もって準備はなし
宿題ではなくて いろいろマニュアルやらいろいろそれを何もなくその場で対応する
その場で対応するために心はすごく穏やかで観察能力を持っている
だから構えて生きていればいいということで
分かりやすく言えばね
出てこいと だから人生の中で安全安心感というのは探さない方がいいんです
海の中にいるんだからね
それでお釈迦様はもう悟り
解脱というものはあるんだよと
だから解脱という言葉さえもはっきりとこの海の中にいるんだから使ってるんです
海の中では安心感がないんです
だからとにかく浮いている
だからこれがちょっと一休みしようっていうとありえないんですよ
もう あ 夜だから まあ海の真ん中にもう落ちてる人
あ 夜だから寝る時間だぞ
じゃあ寝るぞと 寝る時間ないんです
人生には そういう風に人生見るんですよ
一つ終わるとまた別なものが起きてるんです
それが不幸やと思っちゃうと
それは不幸です 確実に
まあ例えばもう退職して
もう楽しくいい旅でもして
もういろいろなところに
好きなところで奥さんと一緒に行きましょうかなと計画立てて
退職してもう 一ヶ月浮かんで何か病気に倒れたとかね
これは分かりませんからね
なんで不幸ですか？と思っちゃうと本当に不幸なんですよ
だから次は何が起こるかっていうことはわからない
だから何でもいいんだから構えてればいいでしょ
そういう生き方であって
ヴィパッサナーではその智慧
妄想するなかれと 瞬間瞬間に対応しなさいと
智慧を育ててもらうんですよ
それがやがて解脱するためにも使える
生きるために使える とにかく仏教は二十四時間の生き方そのものなんです
別に何か呪文唱えるとかね
どこかに行ってちょっと祈祷する
お祈りするような 全く別格の仕事じゃないんです
答えたかどうか分かりませんだけど
一応そういう風に感じたんだからね
なんか逃げたいと こんな問題なかった方がいいというふうにね
思っているようなんですけど
問題なかったら済まないんですよ
例えば仕事でももういろんな新しい計画立てたり
立てたり 立てたりする
それが楽しいんですよ
人間はそこら辺怠けが働いて
毎日行って毎日同じ仕事をして帰るならばもういいなと思っちゃいますけど
それがちょっとありえないし
よくない やっぱり次から次へとチャレンジあった方が面白い
どうせ確実にあります
私は人生っていうのはゲームですよと昔本は書いたんですけどね
だからゲームで見れば
ゲームというのは全然敵が一匹も出てこない
ただずーっと出て はいゴールだ
あんなゲームあるんですかね
一番単純なテトリスゲームにしたっても
あの落ちるものが自動的に落ちて自動的に合わせてくれるんだったら
あれゲームですかね だからこのゲームの面白さっていうのはそれなんですよ
敵がいることなんです
それが人生そのものがゲームであると
では勝てるかというと
どんなゲームでももう最後まで行かないんですね
特にコンピューターゲームの場合は
途中でゲームオーバーになるようにプログラム組んでるんです
いくらなんでも ですから我々もいくら踏ん張っても死で終わっちゃいますからね
もっとやりたかったことあったのにとかね
そういうことで やっぱりゲームでアプローチするんですよ
それにはヴィパッサナーの智慧がすごく必要なんです
はい  では大変長い時間ありがとうございました
では最後に先生に参拝で終わりといたします
参拝